how good are you about recycling turns
out plenty of us are not the best at it
and if you
aren't really paying attention some of
the items they actually put in the
recycle bin could lead to a fire
kirsten joyce joining us now that's a
bit alarming kirsten
it is brian republic services tells us
just last year
in north america there were 315 fires at
recycling centers directly related
to lithium-ion batteries they're very
common in rechargeable electronics
too many lithium-ion batteries going
into either recycling bins or trash bags
where they're easily damaged by sorting
equipment
when they make it to the recycling
facilities and they start to burn
so with electronics specifically it's
very important that we dispose of them
properly
rechargeable electronics should never be
placed in a recycling bin
now there are a number of resources to
find out what you can and can't do with
all sorts of electronics including
calltorrecycle.org
earth911.com is also a great one and
republic services it's got a mailbox
mail back
option as well where you can send your
electronics back to have them properly
recycled
go to republicservices.com to find out
more about that
i'm blown away every time i visit the
recycling center we see old
xboxes and playstations and things like
that um
you know keeping things out of the way
stream number one is always going to be
the most sustainable option so if these
things are still
usable maybe you've outgrown them you've
replaced them with newer technology
consider donating them he adds that many
times people confuse the idea of
reuse with recycle where public services
does not have the capacity to take these
things curbside you see these conveyors
workers don't have the ability to take
the items out to second-hand stores and
donate them
so they need you and us to do that
properly at our homes
and for us to take them to the
appropriate places so they can find a
second home
didn't